Spirituális alapok, a munka teológiája.
Jugvelcsel alapján nincs egyetlen
négyzentméternyi terület sem az emberi
létünk egész birodalmában, amely felett
Krisztus, aki mindenek ura, nekiáltaná
az enyém. Abbraham Kyel.
Ahogy az életünket éljük a világban,
Isten küldetésében járunk. Küldetésünk
túlmutat a távoli helyek
evangelizációján, vagy akár a tanításon
a vasárnapi iskolában. Küldetésünk
értelmet és célt ad életünk teljes
egészének, beleértve a mindennapi
munkánkat is. Bármi, ami ennél kevesebb,
elmarad attól, amit Isten szánt nekünk,
és szétaprózott élethez, valamint
töredezett identitáshoz vezet. Sok
keresztény a munkát egyszerűen eszköznek
tekinti egy cél eléréséhez, és úgy
tartja, hogy a pihenés jó, míg a munka
rossz. Őket is félrevezette a szent és
profán közötti megkülönböztetés. Az a
tévtanítás, hogy csak az egyházban
végzett munka számít valódi főállású
keresztényszolgálatnak.
Ez nem mindig volt így. Ha
visszatekintünk a történelemben,
láthatjuk, hogy a munkát régebben
egészen másképp értékelték. Az ókori
görögvilágban a munkát átoknak
tartották, és úgy gondolták, a
társadalmat úgy kell megszervezni, hogy
néhányan élvezhessék a pihenés áldását,
míg a munkát az alacsonyabb társadalmi
gazdasági helyzetűek és a rabszolgák
végezték. A hétköznapi munka
lealacsonyító volt, kerülendő, és nem
tulajdonítottak neki semmi spirituális
jelentőséget.
Az Ószövetség ellenben nagyra értékeli a
munkát. A zsidók a munkát Isten
teremtési terve részének tekintették.
A teológiai reflexiót olyan emberek
alkalmazták, akik a mindennapi életben
tevékenykedtek. Ellentétben koruk
görögjeivel a zsidó tanítók nem a
tanítványaik adományaiból éltek, hanem
azt várták el tőlük, hogy legyen
mesterségük, amelyből megélhetnek. Az
Újszövetségben Jézus nem hív fel minden
keresztényt arra, hogy hagyjon fel a
hétköznapi munkával. Ráadásul
tanításainak nagy része is a hétköznapi
munkából vett témákra épül. Pál apostol
is hangsúlyozza a munkáról alkotott
pozitív szemléletet, arra utasítva
minden keresztényt, hogy folytassa
munkáját és végezze jól. Kolosszeiekhez
írt levél harmadik fejezet 23-24. vers.
Írásaiból nyilvánvaló, hogy Pál továbbra
is sátorkészítőként dolgozott, még
azután is, hogy elhívatott a teljes
idejű szolgálatra.
Apostolok cselekedetei 18. fejezet -től
harmadik versig. Korintusiakhoz írt első
levél 9. fejezet 12-től 18. versig.
Tesszalonikiakhoz írt első levél második
fejezet 9. vers. Úgy tűnik, hogy az
Újszövetség egyháza számára ez volt az
elsődleges minta. A keresztények
munkájukkal dicsőítették az Istent,
ugyanazokat a munkákat végezve, mint a
hitetlenek, de másképp, keresztény
módon. Ezek a korai hívők másképpen
élték életük egészét, és ezzel arra
késztették pogányszomszédjaikat, hogy
szavaik és tetteik alapján mérlegeljék
annak a hitnek az igazságát, amelyet
hirdettek. E korai hívők valóban só és
világosság voltak a saját kultúrájukban.
és radikálisan megváltoztatták a világot
Krisztus halála és feltámadása után az
első néhány évszázadban. A harmadik
század végére a görög gondolkodásmód
elkezdett hatni az egyházatyákra, és
lassan megváltozott az a pozitív
szemlélet, amely minden munkát Istennek
végzett cselekedetként értékelt. Amikor
a kereszténység a római birodalom
hivatalosan elismert vallásává vált,
elkülönült egymástól a papság és a
laikusok csoportja, utóbbiakat
másodrendű helyzetbe sorolva. A hivatás
szent és világi kategóriákra bontása
háttérbe szorította az Újszövetség azon
szemléletét, hogy minden hívő az
egyetemes papság tagja, amit később
Luther Márton idézett fel újra. Péter
első levele második fejezet negyediktől
10. versig. A 16. Századi reformátorok
Luther munkásságát követve elkezdték
helyreállítani a munkáról szóló bibliai
tanítást, elismerve, hogy az élet minden
területe, beleértve a hétköznapi munkát
is, Isten elhívásaként érthető meg.
Luther szerint azzal tehetünk eleget a
felebarát iránti szeretetre szóló
felhívásnak, hogy teljesítjük a
mindennapi munkával járó kötelességeket.
Ez a munka magában foglalja a háztartási
és társadalmi feladatokat, valamint a
munkavégzésünket is. Luther
hangsúlyozta, hogy a mindennapi
körülmények között szolgálhatjuk igazán
Istent, és minden olyan próbálkozás,
amely a szemlélődő életet jelentősebbnek
tüntetné fel, hamis. Luther Márton
felismerte, hogy nemcsak azok végeznek
szent szolgálatot, akik az egyházi
hivatalokban szolgálnak, hanem a
mindennapi munka is lelki jelentőséggel
bír. A szerzetesek és papok munkái
bármennyire is szentek és fáradtságosak,
Isten szemében semmiben sem különböznek
a földeken dolgozó egyszerű földműves,
vagy a háztartási teendőit végző asszony
munkájától. Minden munkát kizárólag a
hit alapján mér meg Isten. Luther
Márton. 30 évvel később Kálvin János
tovább finomította ezt a szemléletet,
azt tanítva, hogy a közéleti
tevékenységekbe való bekapcsolódáshoz a
teológia adja a keretet. Kifejtette, a
Szentírás nézőpontja szerint a munka a
spirituális tanúságtétel és szolgálat
átmeneti állomásává válik. Egy mindennap
bejárt híd a teológia és a társadalmi
etika között. Más szavakkal a hívő
munkája szent gondoskodás, és a feladata
teljesítése során vagy hitelesíti, vagy
megsérti a keresztény tanulságtételt.
Ezzel a nézőponttal az üzleti élet egy
olyan kiemelt helyé válhat, ahol hitünk
cselekvéssé válhat. Minden alkalommal,
amikor egy feladatot végzünk, vagy
döntést hozunk, lehetőségünk nyílik
arra, hogy partnereinknek, ügyfeleinknek
és munkatársainknak valami mást
mutassunk. A Krisztus iránti szeretet
példázhatjuk azáltal, hogy önmagunkat
áldozzuk mások szolgálatáért.
Kézzel fogható módon megmutathatjuk,
hogy számunkra az emberek fontosabbak,
mint a profit. A hitünknek kell
befolyásolnia a termékünk vagy
szolgáltatásunk minőségét, a bánásmódot
az ügyfelekkel, az árképzést, a
munkavállalók fejlesztését, a
konfliktuskezelést
és az üzleti tevékenységünk minden egyéb
aspektusát.
Ez a munka teológiája nehéz időket él
meg a posztmodern világban. Az egyház
hagyta, hogy a munka és a vallás külön
entitássá váljon, és megdöbbenve
tapasztalja, hogy ennek eredményeképpen
az üzleti élet kizárólag önző és
pusztító célokat szolgál, míg a világ
közömönbössé vált a vallással szemben.
Hogyan is érdekelhetne bárkit egy olyan
vallás, amely életük jelentős részében
látszólag nem foglalkozik? Minden
evangéliumi keresztény elismeri, hogy az
élet minden területét Krisztus átfogó
uralma alatt kell élni. A Szentírás azt
tanítja, hogy nincs különbség szent és
világi között. Az egyházi munka vagy
misszió nem spirituálisabb, mint bármely
más hivatás, mint például a jog, az
üzleti élet, az oktatás, az újságírás
vagy a politika. Isten királysága az
élet minden dimenziójára hatással van,
és a királyság ügynökei sóként és
világosságként szolgálnak mindenhol,
ahová a lélek vezeti őket. A Bibliában
sokszor szerepel a munka. Ez a kifejezés
különböző formáiban több mint 800
alkalommal fordul elő, gyakrabban, mint
az imádás, zene, dicsőítés és éneklés
szavak összesítve. Eugene Peterson ezt
így magyarázza: "A Biblia azzal a
kijelentéssel kezdődik, hogy kezdetben
teremtette Isten, nem pedig azzal, hogy
dicsőségesen ült a mennyben. Teremtett,
valamit tett, valamit létrehozott,
megalkotta az eget és a földet. A
teremtés hete egy munkahét volt." A
szentírás kezdetétől azzal az
elkerülhetetlen következtetéssel
szembesülünk, hogy maga Isten is munkás.
Ez része jellemének és természetének. A
teremtés könyvének első két fejezete
alapot ad Isten munkával, kultúrával és
az ember felelősségével kapcsolatos
nézeteinek. A teremtés könyve második
fejezetének 15. versében olvashatjuk:
Fogta tehát az úristen az embert, és
elhelyezte az Édenkertjében, hogy
művelje és őrizze azt. Az embert azért
teremtette, hogy munkával ápolja és
védje az ő teremtését.
Az emberi munka tehát Isten eredeti
terve szerint dicsőíti őt és szolgálja
embertársainkat.
Nem a bűnbeesés miatt jött létre munka,
de azt tette elkerülhetetlenné, hogy a
munka néha frusztráló vagy látszólag
értelmetlen legyen. Ádám munkája a
kertben minden munka metaforájaként
értelmezhető. A teremtés történetében
azt látjuk, hogy Isten rendet hoz létre
a káoszból. Egy kertész hasonlóképpen
tesz. kreatívan használja a
rendelkezésére álló anyagokat, hogy
azokat átrendezve további az emberiség
számára hasznos erőforrásokat hozzon
létre. Egy kertész nem parkőr, aki
mindent úgy hagy ahogy van. Tim Keller
egy egyszerű meghatározást ad a munkára.
A nyersanyagok átrendezése egy adott
területen, hogy annak potenciálját
mindenki javára kibontakoztassuk.
Ez volt Ádám feladata a kertben, és ez
az, amire ma mi is meghívást kapunk a
munkánk során.
Szeretünk olyan terméket vagy
szolgáltatást kínálni, amely annyira
vonzó és értékes, hogy az emberek
szívesen fizetnek érte, és a bevételből
minden résztvevőt elláthatunk, valamint
a jövőbe is befektethetünk.
Ezzel az üzleti modellel egy vállalkozás
pénzügyileg támogathat más karitatív
szolgálatokat, és önfenntartó
szolgálattá is válhat. Képes működni
külső támogatás, állami források és
adókedvezmények nélkül. Követhetjük Pál
modelljét, amelyről a tesszalonikiakhoz
írt második levelében, a második fejezet
kilenc versében ír: "Hiszen emlékeztek
testvéreink a mi fáradozásunkra és
veszöttségünkre. Éjjel és nappal
dolgoztunk, hogy senkit meg ne
terheljünk nálatok, és úgy hirdettük
nektek Isten evangéliumát." Néhány
keresztény nehezen tudja összeegyeztetni
a szolgálat és a profit fogalmát, hiszen
a pénz minden rossz gyökere nem igaz. A
Timóteushoz írt első levél hatodik
fejezetéből származó gyakran
félreértelmezett igehely valójában azt
mondja, mert minden rossznak gyökere a
pénzszerelme,
amely után sóvárogva egyesek
eltévejedtek a hittől, és sok fájdalmat
okoztak önmaguknak. A pénz vagy profit
önmagában nem gonosz, de könnyen
bálvánnyá válhat, amely elválaszt minket
Istentől, ha helytelenül összpontosítunk
rá. Jézus figyelmeztet arra, hogy ne
gyűjtsünk kincseket magunknak, és ne
szolgáljunk két Urat. Máté evangélium a
hatodik fejezet. De mindig hangsúlyozza,
hogy ezek az állítások a szív
állapotával vannak összefüggésben. Jézus
arra figyelmeztet, hogy ne alapozzuk a
biztonságunkat mulandó gazdagságra, és
ne áldozzuk odaadásunkat Istenen kívül
valami másnak. De Isten elvárja a
megtérülést. A talentumok példázata,
Lukács 19. fejezet, Máté 25. fejezet
világosan mutatja ezt. A példabeszédben
egy férfi elutazott és távolléte alatti
javakat bízott szolgáira. mondván:
"Kereskedjetek, amíg vissza nem jövök!"
Amikor visszatért, magához hívatta
azokat a szolgákat, akiknek a pénzt
adta, hogy megtudja, ki hogyan
kereskedett. Lukács evangéliuma 19.
fejezet 15. vers. Azok a szolgák, akik
nyereséget tudtak felmutatni, dicséretet
kaptak, és még többet bíztak rájuk. De
az, aki nem gyarapította a rábízott
vagyont, szigorú dorgálásban részesült,
és kidobták. Luther Marton nem prédikált
a profit ellen, ehelyett azt tanította,
hogy becsületesnek kell lennünk a
munkánkban, és a profitnak helyesnek és
tisztességesnek kell lennie. Luther úgy
tekintett az üzletre, mint a legfőbb
parancsolat második részének
megvalósítására.
Szeresd fel barátodat, mint önmagadat.
Márk evangéliuma 12. fejezet 31. vers.
Ezért arra a következtetésre jutott,
amikor eladsz valamit az egy felebarátod
felé irányuló cselekedet, amelyet a
törvénynek és a lelki ismeretnek kell
irányítani, hogy ne okozz neki kárt és
sérelmet. Nagyobb gondod legyen arra,
hogy ne árts neki, mint arra, hogy
nyereséget szerezz magadnak. Más
szavakkal az embereket a profit elé kell
helyeznünk. Mi a Bidenbo Companiesnél
hisszük, hogy a mi vállalatunk Isten
vállalkozása, és mi vagyunk az ő
intézői. Igyekszünk a legjobban
gazdálkodni azzal, amit mesterünk ránk
bízott, és amikor visszajön, szeretnénk
eredményeket felmutatni. Amikor
nyereséget termelünk, azt továbbra is
Isten tulajdonának tekintjük, amellyel
az ő királyságának terjesztése és az
örökre szóló befektetési megtérülés
érdekében kell sáfárkodnunk, akár a
saját falainkon belül, akár azokon
kívül. Befektetési megtérülés,
teljesítménymérő mutató, amelyet gyakran
használnak az üzleti életben annak
meghatározására, hogy mennyire hatékony
egy befektetés. Úgy, hogy a profitot
összehasonlítják a költségekkel. Az örök
befektetési megtérülés azt jelenti, hogy
a kívánt megtérülés nem csak a pénzügyi
beszámolóinkban szereplő profit, hanem
akár spirituális jellegű is lehet.
Dönthetünk úgy is, hogy mindezt
eladományozzuk. Az egyik évben Isten
arra vezetett minket, hogy nettó
profitunk több mint 85%-át
más szolgálószervezeteknek adjuk. máskor
arra irányított, hogy azt újra
befektessük az ő házépítő
vállalkozásába, vagy más Isten
királyságát szemelőtt tartó
vállalkozásokba.
Míg egy amerikai törvény a nonprofit
szervezeteket szigorúan szabályozza, és
azok kötelesek egy meghatározott
összeget adni arra, amit a kormány
programkiadásoknak minősít, az Úr
szabadon felhasználhatja a nyereségünket
bármire, ahogy jónak látja. nincs
korlátozva abban, hogy mit tehet vele.
Lehet, hogy egy időre felhalmozza, újra
befekteti, megosztja az
alkalmazottainkkal, ügyfeleinkkel,
partnereinkkel, más vállalkozásokkal
vagy szolgálatokkal, amelyek szintén
Isten királyságát építik. A hívők
munkája olyan jelentőséggel bír, amely
messze túlmutat a kézzel fogható
eredményeken. Isten számára a munkát
végző személy szíve ugyanolyan fontos,
mint a munka eredményei. Nincs különbség
a spirituális és a világia, vagy a szent
és a profán munka között. Minden emberi
munka, bármilyen alantas is, képes
dicsőíteni Istent. A munka egyszerűen
egy dicsőítő cselekedet, egy
potenciálisan produktív, dicsőítő
cselekedet. Az ősi héberek mélyen
megértették, hogy hitük és munkájuk
miként fonódik össze az életükben. Nem
kell tehát meglepődnünk, hogy ugyanazt a
szót használták a munkára és az
imádatra. A Héber Avodach szó egyaránt
jelent munkát, imádat és szolgálatot.
Ennek a héber szónak a különböző
alkalmazásai megmutatják, hogy Isten
eredeti terve és vágya az, hogy munkánk
és imádatunk eggyé váljon. Egyes
versekben az avodach jelentése munka,
például fizikai munka a mezőn. Más
versekben pedig a magasságos
istentiszteletét jelenti. Az avodach a
hitnek az integrált képét mutatja, egy
olyan életet, ahol a munka és az Isten
imádása ugyanabból a gyökérből,
ugyanabból az alapból ered. Munkánk
nagyon fontos Istennek. Az Istentől
kapott tehetségünk kitartó
fejlesztésével keresztényként érettebek
leszünk, és hasznosabb tagjává válunk
Isten királyságának és az emberi
társadalomnak. Hűséges munkánkkal, Isten
kreativitását, rendjét és a szépség és
kiválóság iránti tiszteletét utánozzuk.
A reformátorok ezt tisztán értették, és
ennek eredményeként a protestáns egyház
a reformáció idején érte el a legnagyobb
kulturális hatását, a művészet, az
irodalom, a zene és társadalmi
intézmények terén. Ennek a tanításnak az
újbóli felfedezése lehetővé teheti a mai
keresztényeknek is, hogy ismét
befolyásolják kultúrájukat. Az a
gondolat, hogy keresztény tanítványi
mivoltunkat munkánkon keresztül fejezzük
ki, az élet fontos része. De meg kell
értenünk a munkával kapcsolatos
feszültséget is, amely a szentírásban is
jelen van. Nem lehet értelmes életet
élni munka nélkül, de a munkát nem
szabad életünk értelmévé tenni.
Keresztényként az identitásunkat
Krisztusban kell megtalálnunk, nem pedig
a munkánkban. Ugyanakkor a munka az
elsődleges módja annak, hogy
válaszoljunk Isten hívására az
életünkben, sóként és világosságként
jelenve meg az íztelen és sötét
világban.
Ennek a munkaszemléletnek értékelnie
kell a pihenés helyét és a szemlélődő
életmód dimenzióit is, valamint azt,
hogy ezek hogyan integrálódnak a munkás
életünkbe. Isten a hetedik napon
megpihent a munkája után, és nekünk is
ezt kell tennünk. Végül meg kell
értenünk, hogy a munkáról szóló
keresztényt által Isten megváltoztatja a
kultúrát. A keresztények nem
elégedhetnek meg egyszerűen az egyéni
megtérésekkel vagy elszigetelt
enklávékkal.
Isten arra hív minket, hogy szentek és
elkülönültek legyünk. Ugyanakkor aktívan
tevékenykedjünk társadalmunk minden
szegmensében Isten királyságának
terjesztőiként.
Isten kiválasztott a világból egy népet
magának, és visszaküldi népét a világba,
hogy az ő szolgái és tanúi legyenek
azért, hogy terjesszék az ő királyságát,
építsék Krisztus testét és dicsőítsék az
ő nevét. Lozáni szövetség.